water scarcity is one of the biggest
challenges facing the world today he'll
work for a fee through sabmiller and
this morning we had a session with lots
of other large businesses with NGOs and
with government ministers with different
departments to talk about how water
under pins economic growth and it's
important that all businesses challenge
themselves to become much more water
efficient we have a stretching target to
prove our water efficiency by twenty
five percent by 2015 but we need to go
much further and that's why working with
partners like WWF and they're in the
session this morning to protect
watersheds that communities the end on
businesses depend roads and farmers
depend on line and it's still a big
challenge all the scarcity will be a big
challenge by 2030 will have a
demand-supply gap of about forty percent
now we must work together to be water
smart to make sure that has an effect
development and it doesn't affect growth